okay ladies you can maybe ride off into
the sunset with a prince if you're
really hot but now social media has us
all convinced that we're just eights
nines and tens and you see girls in the
media you know that
are convinced they're eights nines and
eights nines and tens and you convince
average chicks that we can just have
these crazy outcomes and it's so funny
because I just think in the old
generation you would see like TMZ and
you would see all of these celebrities
but you knew it wasn't real life but
because us chicks you know have access
to these guys we would never in a
million years have access to it makes us
live like not you know real lives until
we hit like 35 and you know everything
crashes down but you never know they
could just take away women's right to
vote and this whole thing would be done